(humming ring)
(audience applause)
On the second day in Korea,
I decided to visit the historic Noryangjin fish market
and I brought my korean teacher, Jin Shia, with me.
(speaks Korean)
(responds in Korean)
What the...
What is...What kind of fish is that?
(speaks Korean)
(audience chuckles)
They bow very deeply does
that does mean they think I'm old?
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
But I'm not that old.
I'm a young... Look at me, look.
Does this seem like an old man to you?
(audience laughs)
Those are not old man movements.
(Jin giggles)
Look, I'm like a cat.
Hi, how are you?
Where are you from?
We are from Hong Kong.
Hong Kong.
Yes.
Are they about
to commit a bank robbery?
What's going on here?
(audience laughs)
What is this?
Kaebul.
Kaebul. Kae means fake.
Fake.
Bul means, like,
male down there, like, there.
(audience laughs)
Down where?
Like.
Use the stick.
(audience laughs)
Oh!
Yes.
Oh my god, It's a fake penis.
Yeah.
(audience groans and laughs)
Here's a guy that loves his work.
People will often eat that.
They like to eat that.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
You can touch it if you want.
I can touch it if you want.
Yeah.
Oh, I know. I don't need to come here.
If you like.
(audience laughs)
Wow.
(audience groans and yells)
I haven't felt one of these since summer camp.
(Conan and audience laugh)
No. Not good?
Not good.
(speaks Korean)
Thank you for letting me hold the penises.
(audience laughs)
Apparently this fish market
is also a motorcycle race course.
Come through. (speaks Korean).
Maybe you could give me some tips
on how to better connect with Korean people.
Make a good connection.
(speaks Korean complimant)
Nun? What's nun mean?
Nun, eyes.
Oh, you have beautiful eyes.
Yeah.
(speaks Korean compliment)
(audience laughs)
What did I do wrong there?
(speaks Korean compliment)
Yeah, and very beautiful smile.
(Jin speaks Korean)
(Conan repeats Korean)
(Conan speaks Korean)
Look at that.
How does one eat this?
You can eat it raw, some people eat
just full thing into their mouths.
But doesn't it then take over your body like an alien?
Doesn't it burst out through the stomach?
I'm going to buy this as a pet.
No pet, no pet.
What's her business?
She doesn't care what I do with it.
This is going to be my pet
and he is going to live with me and my family
and his name is Samuel.
(audience cheers)
Hi Sammy, what's going on?
(audience laughs)
(Korean music)
Unfortunately, I was unable
to bring Samuel back to California with me
without breaking a number
of foreign, state, local, and national laws.
So, I took Samuel here to the COEX Aquarium in Seoul.
I want him to live a happy life.
(audience cheers)
These people will take good care of Samuel.
These guys, by the way, are all natural predators.
They can't wait for him to come out and play.
Look at this guy. Chomp, chomp.
Thank you so much for taking care of my octopus.
Samuel is actually a female.
Samuel's a female?
Yes.
Really? How do you know a male
from a female octopus?
(speaks Korean)
(audience laughs)
They have different legs.
My work here is done.
I took a pretty much $1 octopus from a fish market
that people just eat regularly,
and brought here to an aquarium
where thousands and thousands of dollars
will be spent to care for it.
This is Conan O'Brien saying, I've ruined another country.
(audience laughs)